coming today to the Virginia Historical
Society for this very wonderful
opportunity in book signing we're proud
to introduce Suzanne fence dodd author
of the first in-depth biography of
warren beatty suzanne received her
education in texas graduating with a
bachelor's degree from the university of
texas in french literature she continued
her postgraduate studies in the legal
field at the London School of Economics
and the University of Grenoble she then
returned to Texas and received her
doctorate of jurisprudence degree from
the Bates College of Law at the
University of Houston her work as an
estate litigation lawyer consisted of
only one client the Howard Hughes estate
and she wrote her first book titled heir
not a parent about her experiences as a
young law clerk and lawyer on the Howard
Hughes estate case since that time
Suzanne has written a number of books
including the award-winning biography of
Natalie Wood called
Natasha two of her books Natasha and
sleeping with the devil were made into
movies made for TV Suzanne currently
lives in Los Angeles but tells me that
she's fallen in love with Virginia and
who couldn't help themselves when they
come to Virginia and is investigating
writing and another book about another
of Virginia's celebrated artists I would
like to ask that you have any questions
for Suzanne after her presentation that
you walk to the microphone as I
explained to you earlier and just ask
you a question
clearly again you will not hear your
voice magnified in the room but believe
me it's being recorded for c-span and
all the world to hear when this airs
Suzanne will be in the museum shop to
sign books immediately after her
presentation without further ado and
thank you for your patience I'd like to
introduce you mrs. Anthony stop
thank you very much and I have fallen in
love with Virginia no doubt about that
may even move here you never know huh
here it is at long last many years in
the making
I'm going to try this and see if I can
put the nothing coming up it's showing
here but not on screen sorry another
technical difficulty one of the things
I've learned after writing a number of
biographies is there seems always to be
a key to the subject that you're writing
about in the case of Natalie Wood I
found it to be her mother and a very
close kind of symbiotic relationship
between Natalie and her mother with
Horne Beatty I discovered fairly early
on that it was Virginia and the fact
that he is a Virginian and all that that
connotes at least to me is something of
an outsider who's spent time researching
Virginia and spent time here
interviewing a number of the people who
are in the book and to me what that
symbolizes is a sense of honor a sense
of patriotism a sense of decorum a sense
of chivalry those are all traits that
Warren Beatty embodies and so much so
that I in fact there he is thought in
blurry glory thought of calling the book
The Virginian for a time because it's so
much a part of everything that he
represents and in fact I think
engendered in Beatty a sense of conflict
between his sort of Virginia core values
and once he became an actor moved to New
York and then to Hollywood became a
movie star the sort of Hollywood image
of war
as the kind of Casanova or a playboy and
I found that conflict to be really again
another key to understanding the
struggles that he's gone through and
sort of reconciling his Virginia roots
and Warren Beatty the movie star and has
now sort of come full circle and come
back to his Virginia roots and Virginia
values not that he abandoned them but I
think there was more of a sense of a
sense of paradox between Henry Warren
Beatty which is his real name and Warren
Beatty his movie star name and the next
picture and these are all photographs by
the way that are in the book there are
many many more actually one of the
things I'm proud of in the book is that
there are a number of really rare
photographs that are family photos and
other photos photos of Warren Beatty and
those close to him that came from family
albums and a number of celebrated
photographers and photographs that you
wouldn't ordinarily see or come across
the having another glitch here the next
photo here we are this is a photograph
that was taken of Beatty when he was
making his third film called all fall
down and I considered using this
photograph for the cover of the book
to illustrate the paradox that I was
just describing this sense of the
private person and the public image with
the real Beatty we see and then his
image in the mirror and I thought it
sort of really symbolized this duality
this this sort of conflict that he has
internal conflict between these two
aspects of his personality in fact
there's a kind of a funny story that I
was told by Mason Greene who whose
father worked with Warren Beatty's
father in Arlington in real estate and
he was telling me that when the film
shampoo came out which I'm sure you all
remember one of the baby's great classic
films from the 70s but a bit of
a bit of a naughty film by Virginia
standards and Mason Greene's mother was
talking to Warren Beatty's father IRA
Beatty about oh what's Warren's latest
film and he said oh it's this movie
Shampoo and Mason greens mother was
saying well you know I'd really like to
see that movie I want to see Warren's
you know latest film and his father iris
said you know I'm not so sure you'd like
that one because she was about 65 at the
time and he thought maybe better pass on
shampoo so that's and that really is
something that I found has been that
that Beatty is very much aware of and
will often refer to in interviews when
he will talk about his being a Virginian
and what that means to him and as an
example he's talked about the fact that
he didn't want to marry unless he would
remain married to that person that
divorce was not an option for him partly
because he's someone who doesn't like to
fail and also because as he's put it
well I'm from Virginia and in Virginia
we just don't get divorces we don't do
things like that so again it's something
that very much a part of his fiber this
is his father
this is IRA Beatty and taken when he was
a student at the University of Richmond
right here in Richmond and I think you
can see a little bit of Warren in the
photograph I think there's a real sense
of poetry to Ira Beatty in this
photograph he at the time was very much
desirous of being a violinist played the
violin beautifully and in fact just
after this photo was taken he dropped
out of the University of Richmond and
was a bandleader in some of the small
towns Culpeper and various other towns
in in Virginia and played the violin and
that really was his first love was to be
a violinist and he was asked shortly
after this to tour Europe and
apprenticed to a master violinist and I
think it was one of the great regrets of
his life that he turned that invitation
down he felt that maybe he wasn't quite
good enough to make it as a professional
violinist and he didn't want to fail and
instead he went back to school and
decided to become a teacher and in fact
to pursue his PhD getting a PhD became
the substitute for becoming a violinist
he felt that he would be a philosopher
and this is at the time that he was at
that sort of crossroads in his life the
and I'm gonna go back to this one of IRA
Bedi for a moment if I may just to tell
you a bit about the Virginia babies IRAs
I think it was great-great-great
great-grandfather was John Beatty was a
circuit riding preacher in Virginia in
the Shenandoah Valley and there were in
fact several ministers in Warren
Beatty's background which again sort of
informs his sensibility and his sense of
who he is this sense of being from a
long line of Southern Baptists and there
were also farmers the original Henry
Warren Beatty after whom Warren was
named was also a farmer in Virginia and
they were all sort of rooted in Front
Royal so that's where the babies hail
from
this and I'm sorry that this is so
blurred because it's a really remarkable
historic photograph this see if we can
someone working on it back there this
the third person from the left in what
looks like impressionist painting is
Warren's mother Kathleen de mcclain when
she was a student at Acadia University
in Canada she came from a very
illustrious Canadian family her father
was a mayor and a surgeon in Cape Breton
and she longed to be an actress her
mother was a teacher of elocution and
later became the Dean of women at Acadia
University when her husband Warren's
grandfather died young had died
prematurely and kathlynn who was known
as tat this is a stage production of
Little Women at Acadia University and
she's playing Joe and again I apologize
for for the blurry image if you can
imagine the the gentleman who's in the
center of the photograph whose head is
sort of sticking up bats cats brother
Warren's uncle his name was Mansell
MacLean Warren very much looks like him
and he's something of was something of a
prototype for Warren in the family
dashingly handsome guy extremely
intelligent who was in stage productions
with his sister at Acadia and won an an
oratorical Award when he was there he
then went on to become an engineer and
lawyer and was quite prominent he he his
company MacLean Grove was responsible
for constructing the third tube of the
Lincoln Tunnel in New York so very
prominent man and very much an influence
on Warren and that family also Baptist
and again this sort of theme and Beaty's
family of the strong religious
background his mother and grandmother
particularly so
I'm sorry there we go this is the
grandfather McLain I mentioned earlier
who feel like I'm on I'm sort of here we
are here yes this is Murdock McLain
scotch-irish
and in fact Warren's father used to call
Warren's mother Scotch because of the
Scotch Irish background
this is mirto as he was known he was a
surgeon and a quite progressive one in
Canada and was also mayor as I said in
Cape Breton very handsome again you can
see where Warren gets his good looks and
was very much very close to Warren's
mother and kind of an interesting aside
about Warren Beatty's something that
most people wouldn't know other than
friends of his he has an almost
encyclopedic knowledge of Medicine he's
really something of a lay expert in
medicine and he has stated to friends
that he believes that this derives from
his grandfather MacLean who was a
physician and surgeon and in fact when I
was interviewing actress Goldie Hawn she
was telling me that he's he knows so
much about medicine and is so
perfectionistic about anything he does
that she would trust him to remove her
appendix ahead of a surgeon so that's
Warren Beatty's perfectionism and that's
the grandfather from whom he believes
all of this derived both sides of Warren
Beatty's family both the MacLean side
and the Beatty side have political roots
I guess you could say on his mother's
side this is this is Alex McLeod who was
Warren's uncle married to Warren's aunt
Ginny he was an MP and the Canadian
Parliament and in fact was the last
sitting communists in the Canadian
Parliament on the Beatty side of the
family Warren has a great-uncle had a
great-uncle named IRA Partlow
after whom his father IRA Beatty was
named IRA Partlow was the Attorney
General of West Virginia and in fact his
granddaughter is here today
Andrea Winchell is sitting right over
here so I'm honored to have her here and
as well on the Beatty side of the family
Warren's great-grandfather was the mayor
of little Washington Virginia so a lot
of political influence and one can see
from where he derived his interest in
politics and particularly in liberal
politics although interestingly his
father IRA was a Republican whereas his
mother who had this this sort of
left-leaning influence and her family
was much more liberal misses his aunt
Ginny who was married to Alex McLeod the
MP I just showed a moment ago she was an
actress in Canada primarily in Toronto
and one of the kind of interesting back
stories about one of Beatty's great
classic films Reds is that this couple
his aunt Ginny and his uncle Alex were
something of an inspiration to him in
wanting to make the movie Reds in
associating them with Louise Bryant and
John Reed so in part he felt that the
film Reds was a tribute to his aunt and
uncle and in fact their son David was
one of the producers on that film so it
was very much a kind of personal labor
of love for Beatty which I found to be
true of almost every one of the films
where he's been a filmmaker not just an
actor but writer director or producer
that there's typically some kind of
personal connection that he has to the
material and that it often derives from
something from his past from his family
or something in his life as with as with
Reds this is a photograph from Reds just
showing Warren Beatty and his then more
Diane Keaton playing Louise Bryant and
John Reed and Reds
this is Warren's mother as I say was
brought up in Nova Scotia and she made
her way somewhat mysteriously no one's
quite sure why this why this was so but
she came from Canada to Alderson West
Virginia where she taught at a junior
college she taught elocution and this is
her portrait on the faculty at the
Alderson junior college she's the second
from the bottom and though you can't see
it well you can see it in the book well
I think she looks very much like Shirley
MacLaine in this photograph and very
much like Shirley and Sweet Charity if
you remember that movie a similar kind
of Bob to her hair and at the time she
was she was desperately interested in
becoming an actress and she wanted to be
a film actress she was appearing on
stage but she wanted to be in the movies
and just above her it was her best
friend and I was hoping that her
daughter was going to try to be here
today she's a state senator in this area
and she had political political
commitment and she couldn't be here but
that was tatts best friend and there are
wonderful stories about the two of them
in Alderson in the book but really
interesting you can particularly see
through the eyes that the Shirley
MacLaine look and but you can't see it
in this black-and-white photograph
that's where Shirley got her sort of
henna Auburn colored hair was from her
mother
this is the house in Waverly Virginia
the after tat Warren's mother came to
West Virginia she accepted another
teaching position also teaching
elocution as speech was then called and
she taught drama as well at the Maryland
College for Women and Ira Beatty
happened to be teaching there at the
same time while he was taking classes
toward his PhD at Johns Hopkins and it
was at the Maryland College for Women
that TAT and I remanded and married
during their third year teaching there
with the expectation that IRA would get
his ph.d and would be a Doctor of
Philosophy and it was at that point that
the family moved to Waverly and moved
into this house and I'd like to read you
a section from the book if I may that
concerns IRA and tats moved to Waverly I
thought it might be of interest to you
Virginians who are here
instead of starting the summer of 1932
as dr. and mrs. Beatty IRA and tat left
Lutherville Maryland for the small town
of Waverly Virginia where IRA accepted a
job as school principal it was there
that Shirley MacLaine would be born and
Warren Beatty conceived
Kathlyn Beatty later described their
move to Waverly as the decision made
necessary by the depression but in truth
IRA Beatty had lost his confidence
resigning himself to a life of caution
the little episode at Johns Hopkins
probably blunted his opportunities to
achieve what he was otherwise capable of
analyzed a friend of 30 years
Waverly the baby's new home was in
amiable little town about 60 miles south
of Richmond that hailed itself as the
peanut capital of Virginia when Shirley
MacLaine became a star magazine profiles
either omitted waverly from accounts of
her childhood or erroneously reported
that MacLaine spent her early years in
Waverly Virginia on a peanut farm her
parents in fact rented an ordinary white
shingle house with dormers and a
screened-in porch in the center of town
at 3:07 Gray Avenue and may I stop for a
moment here to thank Senator almond Gray
who was responsible for setting up this
wonderful event here today it was his
suggestion that we do this at the
Historical Society and in fact Gray
Avenue was named for his in honor of his
family
the only thing distinctive about the
snug frame house where both Shirley
MacLaine and Warren Beatty were
conceived was the interior which their
mother decorated in a style that was
avant-garde for Waverly Virginia in 1932
showcased by a bold red kitchen accented
by a slick black lacquer ceiling it was
kinda arty was the polite description of
the family who lived there next
Kathlyn Beatty perhaps was expressing
her frustration at being the wife of the
local principal in a once cool Virginia
town as well as her acute disappointment
in her husband a sentiment shared sadly
by IRA himself they kept their
disillusionment painfully concealed the
dignified Murdo and Blanche MacLaine had
taught tat
to burden others with her feelings IRA
repressed his emotions in drinking the
babies may have considered their stature
diminished by IRAs position as principal
of the Waverly school and Kathleen's
role as his muse but they left an
indelible imprint on the community and
on the students they taught who exalted
them
Waverly which had a population of less
than 2,000 was dominated by two genteel
Virginia families the greys and the
West's the former Elizabeth West a
student of the beatty's regarded it as a
rare privilege for us to have the babies
there it was the depth of the depression
to have people like that he was
brilliant and she was talented and
brilliant they did wonders tat and IRA
beatty's interactions with the Waverly
students offered a revealing glimpse of
the way they would shape the
personalities of their two oscar-winning
children and of their own musical and
dramatic talents begging to be expressed
Beatty formed a school orchestra at
Waverly and became its conductor which
called to mind his stint as a dance band
leader in the 20s and put into practice
his doctoral studies on the effect of
music on schoolchildren he also directed
the school's glee club he really was
interested in encouraging young people
to do their best
recalled Mary grammar Tyler who was in
the glee club I remember seeing him play
the violin to illustrate to the students
what should be done Hannah Allen the
teacher most admired at Waverly school
considered Ira Beatty an excellent
educator baby who taught algebra in
addition to his duties as principal set
high standards and used innovative
techniques Mary Tyler recalled he did
something I had never heard of before
nor after he had a student stand in a
line and one by one we would be given a
problem
which we would do in our heads if we
couldn't do the problem we had to sit
down very much the same as a spelling
bee it was a real exercise for the mind
IRA Beatty blossomed in the esteem of
the Waverly community Elizabeth West who
was a popular a Janu in 1932 when Beatty
became
I found him very dapper in a shirt and
tie every day with trousers fashionably
creased he was a handsome dude and very
stately observed West's younger cousin
Elmen gray who had become a state
senator and was then in second grade
gray was scared to death of principal
Beatty as were many of the primary
school students in experience his
daughter Shirley would have in a few
years he would roam around the school
you would see him he was imposing though
Beatty was considered lazy by a few
Waverly parents he demanded perfection
especially in music he required
successful results as Mary Tyler put it
Elizabeth West's experience foreshadowed
Ira Beatty as a father when West whom
Beatty considered a talented pianist
paid more attention to her teenage
boyfriends than to practicing before a
concert he let me know and no uncertain
terms that he was very disappointed in
me and thought that I was wasting a gift
a talent and he shamed me West was
shaken by Beatty's harsh response but I
must admit I did go on and major in
music in college he apparently had more
appreciation of what I was about than I
did Kathlyn Beatty though more reserved
than her husband was dynamic in her
influence in Waverly
when IRA was principal from 1932 to 1936
she made an enormous impression on my
young mind said Elizabeth West who is a
pretty sociable teen westgate as
kathlynn swept into the school
auditorium on cold days hurt all live
frame elegantly wrapped in a long
raccoon coat her enunciation her home
manner was Grace I even at that age
could appreciate anybody who could come
in and pull talent out of a country high
school Warren Beatty's mother staged a
full-scale Musical at Waverly school
Elizabeth West who co-starred in a
two-person play nevertheless directed by
mrs. Beatty was moved to tears by tatts
staging of the song blue moon performed
by a younger
all alone on the stage beside a blue
velvet curtain in a dress that was a
contrasting exquisite shade of blue mrs.
Beatty just did incredible wonders with
the lighting system at that time and
made her skin just look like moon glow
and it was just
ooh and chanting she made us feel like
well there was Hollywood in Waverly
Virginia
Kathlyn Beatty had inherited her mother
Blanche's perfectionism another trait
that would be instilled in her son
Warren who would show a similar
aesthetic creating the color palette for
his film Dick Tracy mrs. Beatty was so
exacting and such a perfectionist and we
worked so hard but oh the way she would
drill me in elocution and enunciation
recalled West tat had her students
recite phrases like around the rough and
rugged rock to improve their
pronunciation an idea Warren Beatty lady
later borrowed and apparently I need to
employ for the film Bugsy where his
character repeats an elocution exercise
20 dwarves took turns doing handstands
on the carpet
the baby's second Ottoman Waverly
Kathlyn became pregnant soon after her
30th birthday Shirley MacLaine's said
later that her father had an eighth
sense about women and knew when tad had
conceived before she did demonstrating a
mystic sensitivity to women's cycles
that Warren Beatty reportedly inherited
and put to different use
Kathlyn Beatty passed the early months
of her pregnancy with Shirley by taking
daily walks while IRA worried about
supporting a child in February of 1934
when tap was 7 months pregnant
Beatty focused on a new smaller dream he
wrote to the Registrar at Johns Hopkins
stating that he hoped to get his name on
the approved list of school
superintendents in Virginia the
Registrar agreed not to reveal that
baby's dissertation had been rejected
and informed him that he could present
himself for his final oral examination
for his PhD at any time despite this
favor IRA Beatty was bypassed for a
superintendent's position a cringing
disappointment the
with the birth of his daughter Shirley
on April 24th 1934 a friend of Elizabeth
West's named Margaret retain spotted IRA
and Kathleen Beatty in a cornfield that
April mr. Beatty took her out in the
field so he could walk her through the
rows of corn to induce labor as pertain
recalled an appropriately unorthodox
prelude to the arrival of shirley
maclaine her birth at st. Luke's
Hospital in Richmond was more
conventional the pediatrician was dr.
Wilbur Billy southward iris saxophone
playing buddy from the University of
Richmond southward according to his
embarrassed son was among the
conservative Virginians who would be
shocked by Maclean's New Age beliefs
years later my dad was sort of a
curmudgeon and he said if he had known
how Shirley was going to turn out he'd
have put her back and raised the
afterbirth
Kathlyn Bedi according to MacLaine
determined her daughter's destiny within
20 minutes naming her Shirley after
Shirley Temple IRA Bedi
occasionally babysat his daughter while
he gave private violin lessons keeping
her in a nearby crib
one of his adult violin students also
had a baby Jack Griffin IRA Beatty and
Jack's father placed their infants side
by side in the same crib while the two
men practiced the violin so Jack loved
to say later that he slept with Shirley
MacLaine tattled to chum Jack Griffin's
father and Ira Beatty played violin at
the theater in the next town during
silent movies my dad talked about the
babies up until his death he would say
they're just the finest people I've ever
known Shirley MacLaine Beatty was
remembered in Waverly as a robust
toddler with kind of chestnut colored
hair and a lot of it for a little girl a
snapshot exists of this interlude in the
baby's lives before Warren came along
and I'll show it to you I hope
it was taken during a faculty outing in
the summer of 1933 and kept by Senator
Elmen gray the second grader in 1932 who
was terrified of principal Beatty the
photograph shows the small Waverly
faculty gathered on the lawn in front of
Horace Gray's summer home in Gloucester
Point with IRA Beatty front and center
dressed in a shirt and tie even on a
holiday
he wears a smile that appears strained
and is holding little Shirley up for the
camera in a way that is at once tender
and that seems to announce prophetically
that she not he is the future star
Kathlyn Beatty stands at the rear of the
group her tall frame leaning forward in
the upper right hand corner her head
slightly bowed as she peers up at the
camera
her intelligent eyes squinting in the
Sun with a quizzical expression exactly
like Warren's
and countless movie stills to come by
the end of the next summer Warren had
been conceived and the babies would be
gone from Waverly and I'm sorry again
about the blurriness of this it's such a
great wonderful sort of historic
photograph and so Virginian this is a
photograph of Warren and Shirley after
they moved to Richmond after the family
moved to Richmond and is the photograph
that Beatty would later view with great
sentimentality he was on a talk show
once and Shirley had sent this
photograph to the studi studio he wasn't
aware of it and the host showed him this
photograph and he stared at it for a
very long time very moved by it and very
indicative of a extremely strong bond
between the two siblings he would say
later that she was his first crush and
what I found is that a lot of the
girlfriends that Warren had through the
years were in many ways Shirley sort of
in the mold of Shirley often they would
have red hair and almost all of them
would be tremendously talented gifted in
some way or other
in fact one of Warren's friends from
high school
whom very honored to have here Tom
Calhoun told me at one point that one of
the things that Beatty was drawn to as a
young man was was talent that that was
really what was exciting to him and that
was it's true of Beatty not just in
terms of his relationships with women
but people in general he's someone who
has a great eye for talent it's one of
the reasons that he's a successful
producer and this was very much in the
household where he grew up with with
Shirley as a sister and with his parents
who had this great artistic talent that
was somewhat frustrated while he was
growing up in Richmond he was steeped in
politics not just by the family members
his great uncle IRA Partlow who was
Attorney General at the time and would
stop and visit but just being in the
state of Virginia which is of course
known as the mother of presidents and
Warren I suppose not unlike a lot of
six-year-olds at-6 fantasized that it
would be terrific to be president and
that quote has come back to that thought
has come back to haunt him and he's been
quoted often as saying that he wanted to
be President at six and he in his
exacting way would point out that that
was a mistake that he said he just
thought about it he didn't necessarily
say he wanted to be President so this
was all sort of came from this sense of
you can't drive down a street in
Richmond and not come across some sort
of evidence of our patriotic history and
that's something that I think very much
is what defines Warren Beatty
this is a photograph that was taken
after the family moved from Richmond to
Arlington Virginia and Warren became
involved in school politics and he and a
couple of other boys in the school one
of their friends told me that three of
them kind of ran the school somewhat
Warren is the third from the left
in this photograph and he the next year
ran for president of his senior class
and he won and there's kind of a great
story that is I'm sure a lot of people
in Hollywood will chuckle out when they
read the book because Warren Beatty is
famous for his pauses when he speaks
these pregnant pauses in fact there was
a writer for Rolling Stone who
interviewed him once and timed the
pauses they were so long between words
and wrote in his piece that symphonies
could be written during Warren's pauses
and you know very famous for this and in
this speech that he gave his his senior
year so I was told he practiced pausing
for effect during the speech he was at
the time very much impressed with a
youth minister in Arlington Reverend
John Raymond and Reverend Raymond was
also interested in politics and he and
Warren worked on the speech together and
I think from what I was told Warren felt
that he'd been so blessed in terms of
great looks and intelligence and and so
much going for him that he thought he
might be able to elicit sympathy if he
seemed to be hesitating or pausing or
stumbling while he was speaking and it
evidently worked and particularly worked
with the girls in his class and he
indeed was elected president of his
senior class
it was really during the the actually
I'll go back to this one else I'll say
that it was sorry during this period of
his childhood Warren was sort of
conflicted between his interest in
politics in history and sort of the
academics of his scholarly father and
his mother who directed little theater
plays in Richmond and in Arlington and
in fact she put young Warren and Shirley
in some plays when they were children
and this was an actress who was the star
of one of his mother's plays in
Arlington named was June row weaver her
daughter was here actually just a few
minutes ago and Warren who was then 9
was so enamored with June that at the
close of the play he wrote her a formal
proposal of marriage and sent the letter
to her and she kept it her daughter
still has it and that was the first
person that Warren Beatty proposed to
and introduced him to as I write in the
book a different kind of actress than
the sort of serious thespians in the
manner of his mother and his grandmother
this was more of a Hollywood version of
an actress and it's interesting that
he's sort of still got this he this
again duality with the sort of Joan
Collins actresses that he's gone out
with and the Annette Bening Diane Keaton
serious actresses so this all again sort
of stems from his childhood now Shirley
was as impressed with June Weaver as
Warren was for different reasons when
she was a little girl and June was
starring in a play for their mother
Shirley would put out her clothes her
wardrobe before each scene and thought
she was glamorous and beautiful and
aspired to be like her and like Rita
Hayworth and this was Shirley's first
glamour shot as a young actress when she
was in Hollywood still a teenager and I
think you can see traces of June Rowe
Weaver in this
graph of Shirley Warren was torn between
whether to become an actor whether to go
into politics he thought about becoming
a lawyer and this at the time that
Shirley this photograph was taken
Warren was still in high school and
decided ultimately to go to Northwestern
thinking that he might major in law and
having in the back of his mind as he
said later that he had sort of felt that
he came that the family business was
acting and I think he was sort of in
denial possibly even to himself that
that was something that he was
interested in pursuing but indeed did
dropped out of Northwestern after a year
but still has this sense of competition
between politics and acting and
competing for his attention whoops
that's out of order oh I guess we're
missing though don't
hmm there was a photograph of Warren and
Shirley they were both sort of
galvanized by Kennedy in terms of their
political activism Warren I don't know
whether any of you know this but he was
asked to play John F Kennedy and the
film pt-109
turned it down kind of famously or
notoriously and was misquoted at the
time when he was asked to go to
Washington DC to meet with Kennedy and
in fact because he knew he didn't want
to take the part because he felt that
the script wasn't up to either Kennedy
standards or his and someone flippantly
remarked that Warren had said well if he
wants to to have me play him why don't
you have him come to Hollywood and soak
up some of my atmosphere instead of
going to Washington which was a misquote
that actually distressed Beatty greatly
but he and John Kennedy became friendly
after that and he and Robert F Kennedy
became quite close and in fact Beatty
worked in Kennedy's presidential
campaign in the 60s and that was really
sort of the beginning of his political
activism in a serious way it became more
pronounced during the McGovern campaign
that was photograph I was going to show
you was actually a picture of Warren and
Shirley
a Vietnam moratorium in Washington DC
and there was a picture of Warren with
he was in character for the film McCabe
and mrs. Miller I don't know if you
remember that film with Julie Christie
where he plays kind of a frontiersman
had a great burly beard and long hair
and in fact he based that character I
found out on his Virginian relatives and
wrote a lot of dialogue for his
character using some of the vernacular
that he had heard growing up from his
great aunts in Front Royal Virginia so
if you see that movie you'll now know
that a lot of what his character is
saying comes from your part of the
country this was taken this last
Christmas when and he's cut off here but
Warren is on the far right of this
photograph it's when he was honored at
the Kennedy Center and this is with his
wife Annette Bening and their four
children and as an illustration a
profound one of the influence of his
parents unworn and how how important
they are to him each of his four
children is named after his mother or
father and two of them were born on one
was born on his mother's birthday one
was born on his father's birthday now
I'm sure you've been hearing in the news
a lot lately the the rumors that Beatty
may challenge Arnold Schwarzenegger in
the gubernatorial race in California and
he's made a couple of political speeches
that suggest that he has that in the
back of his mind I would never presume
to guess what Warren Beatty is going to
do but he certainly is sort of bringing
stirring the pot I guess you could say
and is bringing to people's attention
issues that he feels are of great
concern and also has said that he feels
it as a celebrity he has a particular
responsibility to point out what he
considers the deficiencies of another
celebrity who has taken public office I
think that because he's such a devoted
father and husband that would probably
be in my estimation one of the great
deterrents to his being actively
involved in politics other than as a
spokesperson and a concerned citizen
but it's this photograph I think sort of
is a perfect example of how he has come
full circle to living the sort of family
values with which he was raised and I'll
close by actually quoting him in a
speech he gave last week to the
California Nurses Association when he
was describing his politics and said
that he acknowledges what he continues
to be an old-time unrepentant
unreconstructed tax and y-z wisely spend
bleeding-heart die-hard liberal democrat
who grew up a Southern Baptist from
Virginia and believes in the Golden Rule
social programs safety net regulation
and an active government thank you very
much
hope this has shed some fresh light on
Warren Beatty and I'd be happy to take
questions from anybody who's here anyone
have a question I guess I was really
thorough in my speech no questions I've
said it all believe me there's much more
to be found out in these 600 pages all
right I know you were not able to speak
to Warren directly well as not an
official biography and of course you
rely on speaking to a number of his
friends and associates because they know
how much he values his privacy did you
ever feel that perhaps they were holding
back protecting him or do you think that
they really opened up on on the subject
I was actually remarkably impressed by
the candor of the people I interviewed
and it's interesting because that's one
of the things that I learned about
Warren and his
is sort of again not to overplay the
theme but this sort of Virginia
background of his what I discovered
about the babies as a family group is
that they're apparently known for their
honesty and I found a couple of
obituaries in obituaries for his
grandfather maybe and his
great-grandfather that actually stated
that the baby men are known for being
honest
they're also parenthetically known for
their great singing voices but that's
another story but known for being
particularly honest and I did I was very
impressed with what I felt to be very
forthright interviews with the people I
spoke to and that was a very happy
surprise because there's no point and
writing a biography if you're not going
to really get under the skin of the
person you're writing about it's kind of
a pointless exercise and you were one of
them I felt was especially candid and
forthcoming so I thank you for that any
other questions from anyone
gosh I'm thrilled that I have been this
comprehensive nothing at all all right
well I'll be happy to sign books and if
anyone wants to ask me anything sort of
more privately when I sign books I'd be
very happy to do so thank you again for
having me it's really been a pleasure
and a particular privilege to be at the
Virginia Historical Society I really
have a great fondness for this part of
the country in Virginia in particulars